hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar save your time on data analysis
with new batch analysis feature in axon
P clamp 11 software I'm Christie jewel
of leverage and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is brought to you by
laberd's and sponsored by molecular
devices now let's get started I would
like to remind all of you that today's
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you like at anytime you
like during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on that support tab
or report your problem by using the ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen you can also share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab and
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
additionally this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits after viewing the
presentation just click on that
continuing education credits tab and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I would now like to introduce
our speaker dr. Geoffrey tang senior
global acts on electrophysiology
application scientist at molecular
devices for a complete biography on dr.
Tang please visit our biography tab at
the top of your screen dr. Tang you may
now begin your presentation
hi everyone thank you for attending this
online webinar my name is Jeffrey 10 a
senior application scientist of action
electrophysiology product line today I'm
going to talk about one of our new
features in 2011 software this amazing
feature is called patch analysis using
patch analysis we save you a lot of time
on data analysis here my agenda today I
will give an overview on peak m11 and I
will talk about how to set up the batch
analysis and how to import the data and
how to use macros and export the data
and I also will do some demonstrations
for data analysis and at the end I will
create a new database
now before I talk about best analysis I
want to give everyone a quick review on
PM 11 software
peak and 11 have two versions standard
and advanced both versions have new
features in context first new features
is then enhanced protocol editor it
increased in you know 50 epochs we
increase from 10 to 15 a box we increase
we also increase this with duration and
also we enhance the gap free mode so
that we can pre-program of handler
output and holding duration and teacher
the output
features that will enhance the in we
improve the membrane test and it
includes the multiple memory test window
can be displayed and also independent
analog output control
however only advanced virgin encruster
Alyce's pop
spaceship and action potential [ __ ]
now this is slide we my you that the
breath tango is for the clamp acts and a
wide-angle is for the clamp is advanced
version now when you order peak and 11
standard version you will be sieved one
rectangle which is four contacts we
order peak and 11th advanced version you
will receive two tango the black one is
for the clamp acts and the y1 is for the
Cranfield
traffic 11 software can be installed in
multiple computers we've done the wide
angle the new features such as
operations by search action potential
search and batch analysis will be grayed
out
with the wide angle insert to the
computer
new features will be displayed
today I will talk about the batch
analysis only
now what is batch analysis now in pm10
if you want to analyze 10 file you need
to open 10 files separately and if each
file take you five minutes to analyze
the data now 10 file will take you 15
minutes in peak and 11 you get open 10
file at the same time but you're still
just use you know five minutes to
analyze 10 fight at the same time that's
what I said
it will save you a lot of time
now let's talk about how to
the batch analysis
now first
download the P chem 11 software for my
comedy website molecular device comm
then navigate to service knowledge space
electrophysiology and go to the download
pages and you can download the PM 11
then you follow the instructions in the
QuickStart guide to configure the MVC 5
server now you can open the MVC file
server through windows start all
programs molecular viruses and an MVC
file server then you just need to
right-click the mouse on the MVC file
server and run as administrator
the file server managers windows open
then you clicks they let the file
directory open a browser log to select
the folder where you want to store it in
the files you click the create a new
folder you type you know the name for
example in here
no file server and click OK
now in the step pot fill ok you tight
for the 9200 and click a prime
you click the start button and wait for
the stop button to disable when the stop
button is inactive click close then the
MDC file server setup is finished this
very easy
now let's talk about how to set up data
storage configuration
now at this point you can use the clamp
it can go to the computer
can be software
let the analyzed and then you can run
the batch analysis after the best
analysis window appears when you see the
storage location message just click OK
when the story location type dialog
appear in here then you just click this
you know read add button just click this
button
now in a display name Phil you can tie
the name for your data file storage
folder at this point as you can type the
file server
servername Phil just verify that the
name of your computer basically should
be your local computer name is correct
or not now in the path field just leave
the default setting as nine to zero zero
and it can triple click to finish then
the data storage configuration setup is
finished this very simple
now let's talk about how to import the
data to batch analysis
now you can open the batch analysis
the file and all and then you can see
that the imported file and you will see
individual file and entire folder now
basically you can import individual
files or entire folder
to the patch analysis
now after you input the data you
go to the configure
you can use you can see that the data
selector hierarchy to display this the
data in order okay
as in the order of the protocol the name
of the protocol or the day of the
experiment day or the name or the time
and you can move you know the upward and
downward arrow on the right hand side to
arrange the sequence of the order
very simple now let's talk about how to
use the macros
you can use the macro to recall analyze
steps
you know for this data file now you
select the macro step see that and
recall
then you enter the micros name
that you can create analyzer steps
click stop button up the finish
safe
now let's talk about how to export the
data
now you see let analysis tab and then go
down you can find the export result
you can export your video to excel five
you can see that what
not be so
and what format
okay then the result will be
automatically exported to excel file as
showing the right-hand side
now I'm going to do some data analysis
demo that to show you how to you know
how to do the data import and also the
data export and also the macros and also
I will do the demo to show how the
amplitude measurement and LTP Pro or
combine the LTP prod in one graph and
also I would do the demonstration for I
Reaper and combine several IV curve to
one IV curve
now I will use the amplitude measurement
to show you how to input the data and
create a marcos and export the data
now what we need to do is that first we
open the data file the data will import
it to theta selector
the foul will be displayed
recording trees also are displayed
and now we can move to
Chris appear to define the baseless
region and a search region
select and the life steps and select the
measurement
we see that the measurement I click OK
at this at this time we just click check
the pit Amba to show in here
and a tepee Amba tool will be measured
then we will be shown in the analyzed
resolved
curve
plot now I am going to switch to the
clan feed to show you this function like
data import macros and data export
now here's the clan feed you go to fetch
analysis you run
window will be open now you can see the
data selector are already input some of
the data in here already okay and then
and then we what we need to do we can go
to the configure
I can show you how to do the import
first we go to the file included import
data file you can see in the video file
and entire folder right but because I
already input the data file but I'm not
going to do that okay and then we can go
to the configure
you can see that the data selector hi
Rocky
now you can see there there's the like
protocol they and name and time and you
can see here the data file is displayed
it in terms of the Porco right now but I
get changed to the day for example I
click the day I use this upward arrow to
move the day to the to the first you
know to the first place and hit okay and
you will see it will changes you know
the display order you can see right now
the data is dissipated you know in terms
of the date now I can
- can change
- the name of the time okay I'll put a
name here you can see the name of the
data file okay now let me go back to sa
protocol and that will be easier or I
can go to the day okay
they will be easier for me do the
demonstration
now in order to show you how to use the
macro now I need to click here the macro
here right
Marco will be here we can he be cool
okay but first of all I need to open the
data file first we can click here open
the data file now in this you know in
this folder I have four data here right
now
before I do any analyzed step I just go
to macro and hit be cool now I can put a
name here first we can put the for
example get a P because I want to
measure for the pit and we have I want
to measure the peak amplitude in this
data file we have 120 traces okay I open
for data file here at the same time I
hit a pit here then after that I will
move my cursor 1 and 2 as the base I
region and 3 and 4 is the search region
I
can
Salette measurement
for the pit AmpliTube at this
demonstration I have the search region
curses three and four I have the cursor
region 1 and 2 as the baseline and it
okay
now we'll edit the graph
see the
two voices at the time you can see the
grab is important the first date of our
second date of our third and four and
you can see also the peak amplitude is
mercy that is measured here now after
this you can hit stop become the macro
will be stopped and at the same time you
if you expand the macro window here now
you will see the pin macro is saving
here okay now I can also can export the
data
for the we saw
select you know the result in analyzed
results data or in dataset diesel and
what kind of form it and it okay
if I will be opened and you can see the
four datafile if the name is displayed
here
Wow buddy pretty quick were you powerful
right
so I closed this one now now let's say
here you know next day okay I also using
the same protocol I also have another
four theta five here okay
the four day the file using the same
protocol now why did you do is that I
just go to analyze I can see let let's
save the mark of the pit then it just
click you know run the macro
see
data is already you know the PMB to was
mentioned and the graph is product
beautiful right so now let me go back to
the PowerPoint okay
now the next demo I want to do is that I
want to prop the LTP prop thing and also
the combined LTP prop what that mean is
that so I have you know i prod a single
LTB prop now I can I can navigate you
know make a combined you know LTB prop
with n equal to 8 how to combine pic of
this LTP you know brought to one graph
with the standard you know Arabah here
right so Nexus why I will show you all
those step first
now this is like this you know you see
only you already saw this slice because
I want you to use you know the same the
mb2 measurement where your DC is a slice
I open the data file and then at this
point because I open all the data file
exit the file for LTP data and then I
have to be coding 3 display I move the
cursor up here right to the search
region and then and then on the base I
region then I see that analyze in the
measurement measurement for the p10
material and then p10 with you it's
calculated and the greatest product so I
have for example I have a data file I
have egg of this curve now how I can
make those egg curve compared to the one
with the error there are standard error
bar
need to do we go to vasila analyzed so
that the of realistic
and then Sims we combined those in LTP
so we need to normalize in each data
file we need to normalize that you know
to the baseline okay to the baseline
okay in this case I normalize that I
normalize that to the average of the
first three data point of the baseline
okay let's do this example now what we
need to type you need to type this you
know this equation of course you can do
more data point if you do file you can
do you can add you know four and five
here right
then
you need to enter the normalized Amba to
in column title need to put a name here
then to normalize that amplitude is
calculated okay and showing the analyzed
in a bizarre
to analyze and select copy the data to
the data set resolve
and then you see
we'll be displayed in this copy to
dataset result in a window you see those
have whatever cob
then move see that the column to the
right and a raised column in order so in
this case I move okay and move the child
name to the right and move the
normalized and reduce to the right
and you can see the data in the data set
Jacque now get the data at this trader
in data set resolve then I go to analyze
and average see that average rose
okay then again in the average roll
window if we see a vertical column they
are displayed and very important is that
you need to move
trés column okay this column to the
right hand side and the average value in
the column you need to select the
normalize the amplitude column in here
then you will see those eras roll are
displayed in the data set my song
then you add graph
then you see let average roll okay start
up trace column for x value and then you
see let the normalize the Amba to the
mean value as the y value and then you
see that the average roll normalize that
mb to standard error for the error bar
then you can combine the egg LTV product
to one graph with standard error bar so
let me go back to the clamp it to show
you how to do that
all right
so let me do it again I want to get all
those LTP you know data from LTP
protocol I go to configure data as
letter Iraqi and put the protocol at the
top now you see the LTP protocol you
know all the data is done using this LTP
protocol and just click here
and you can see a data file is open at
the same time right so then I will go to
measurement
I need to measure for move the cursor
first 1 & 2 as a base I region and three
and four essays search region
then I go to measurement
then I picked the pit AmpliTube
and go to add the graph
a lot trees
see beautiful this LTP data here right
now I need to first of all I need to
normalize you know I need normal at this
point it's data point to the baseline
okay now what I need to do go to analyze
go to everything right I need to put to
tie this equation but then what this
equation mean is that
value in the column ye will be divided
by the average of the first three to the
point okay up the recording trees now
you want you you can add more okay you
want hit four or five data point you can
say add you know II and then do this
right and then press
and II this one right and of course you
need to change to the fine for example
right and then you put double rice and
the 2's output option and it okay
now you see
Amba - is calculate the heat then what
you need to do next is go to copy to the
data set result
the left because you want to prod right
so you need to select right time or
trace to the right hand side and then
normalize the amplitude and of course
you can also can move to the trial name
you can see the challening of the update
data file right so I do this one and hit
OK now you see the data is copied to the
data set result now you can see
chayo name fit and the teal and then
start off trace and normalize the
amplitude right right now the you see
that all the data file
I'm a will be in in one column only here
ok now what I need to do next is that I
need to average the row I will move the
start of trace to the right-hand side
and average you know see that
the normalized amplitude is average
value in column it will calculate the
mean standard error right and hit OK
yep you see those theta here then you
just click that graph
you select for the
which role for start-up tres y for x
value and this one for the normalize the
Amba to the mean for the y value and
then you can see that for this for the
standard error or here for the error bar
now the x-axis right now is displayed in
second you can go to access change to
minute and hit okay
yep so in this demonstration I show you
and how to put 8 LTP you know prop you
know curve combined in let's say 1 you
know LTP curve with the standard or a
bar alright then let me go back to my
next demonstration okay let me go back
to my to my slice okay now what I want
to do next demonstration is that I want
to plot the IV curve okay from many
cells and combine the IV curve in one
for example I have Phi of this single IV
curve and how can I prop you know and
combine them you know to come to prod to
combine the you know the the Phi you
know I will curve as a one with the
standard error bar alright so I'm going
to show you some steps okay first and
into the demonstration
I need to open a pedophile okay and then
I open fighty the file will be displayed
here
then the recording trace also will be
displayed in this window
then I go to you know let analyze and in
order to plot the IV curve I need to
select current and voltage over voltage
and so that wave form a cursor one beta
at crystal one okay yeah
and click OK
now the current amplitude are displayed
it in the analyze result
also the single IV curve is plotted
then you go to analyze select a
realistic
and again you need to because I need to
normalize you know to the maximum value
of each IV curve you just need you just
need to seal it norm ax and put the
column you know for the current there
will be six column C
then you enter normalized current in the
column title
then denominator coding will be
calculated
be shown in the analyzed result
copy the data set enough to copy the
data to the data every song
then in the copy to data service a
window you will see available column
will be displayed at the left-hand side
and then you need to move to select the
column to the right hand side at this
point I move the trial name also I move
to normalize the current to the right
hand side
then the data will be displayed in
telesat bazan as shown in here
then you select analyze and average roll
so you will see in the average row
window the data I mean a variable column
are displayed in the left-hand side
then you need to move the voltage column
right hand side and in the average value
in column you need to select the
normalized curve
then the Aries roll are displayed in the
data set we saw
at Graff
and it will select the average row
voltage for the x value and then you
select the average role normalize the
current to me at the by value and then
you will see let the normalize the
current standard error as error bar
you can edit the axis
and then you can
IV curve is prod
all right let me go back to the clan
feed to the demonstration to you
now at this point I need to select this
data file
this is a very beautiful Ivy you know
curve theta I have pi data file here so
you can move the cursor one and two
by Musco so one okay then I go to
analyze go to the current and voltages
right you see let them wave form the
cursor one and better at a cursor one
and hit okay now you can see the voltage
and the current now I need to normalize
the current to the maximum value now
what I need to do is go to the end
analyze go to arithmetic so I need to
clear this one and go to the function
norm ax is normalized to the maximum and
then because normalized to the current
they put C column C and then you can you
know you can still can say no more I am
batil or you know you can say current
right for example and hit OK now we see
the normalized current is calculated
right right then what I need to do next
step is copy to the dataset we saw
try our name and then normalize current
right you can move to the up right and
hit okay now we see the four five data
file will be displayed in the data step
is all right now I need to next I need
to do is that a visual you need to move
the voltage to the right
this one you see that for the normalized
occur
hit okay
then go to a graph
and then you see that for the average
role rotations and then you see let the
normalized current to me at the y-axis
and then you can see that then normalize
the current standard error and then you
can modify the ax
so you can put zero-crossing
for x axis 0 pausing for the y axis hit
okay
can see the beautiful combined IV curve
is father here
all right it's amazing it's very easy
and really fast now let me go back to my
powerpoint slide
now I find this my demonstration to show
you how powerful of the fashion analysis
but the next question you will meet is
that okay
because the data file in the data
selector cannot be deleted
now you will keep importing the data to
the data selector and you will have a
lot of data in discarding in the data
selector window but they cannot be
deleted so what we need to do is that we
can create a new database ok new
database okay for our to know for the
new database so that you can in you can
empty the data file in this data
selector ok now I'm going to show you
how to do that
so you go to the database tab create the
database okay see that the create a
database and then you tale name order
for your database and click create and
then you select the location where this
new database will be saved on your
computer and you may leave it
to the default location and just click
Save okay now remember that if you get
an error message that the database
cannot be created you need to exit the
clamp it and then B and then we launch
it and start the created database about
and the next to do is that if editing is
going well you will see this message
okay database created successfully and
then you select it new database by going
to the database manual and choose select
database and then you click the button
to open and at the database file and
click OK
and then select the database file and
click open and then click OK
see this storage location then use your
hip you will click OK for that
the rep you know the ad you know the
this rep you know positive sign okay
to add the new storage location
and enter a name for the new file
storage and click OK
then the new database is created
now I come I come to my summary on my
presentation today so you see that the
page the batch analysis saves you a lot
of time on data analysis and you learn
the data file can be sorted in many ways
like protocol time and day and their
name and macro saved analyzes step and
we can you can use the save marcos for
you know for any data file you know
using the same protocol and then the
result can be exported to excel file and
then you can easy to combine you know
the curve with standard error alright so
thank you so much for everyone to attend
my online webinar and i'm open to the
Q&A section
Thank You dr. King for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now if you
have a question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay let's get started
dr. Tang we have some great questions
coming in let's start with this first
one
great on event detection like template
Search single channel search can that be
done in batch analysis oh that is a good
question that the answer is that no we
cannot do the arm that you want
detection by the first row search you
know temperatures and single channel
search or even though like populations
you know search and action places action
potential search in the event detection
no the answer's no I think there's a
reason for that because it is for those
kind of event detection that we need to
you know sometimes the signal the
amplitudes difference so for example in
the temperatures we need to create our
own template way so that's why it is it
sounds good idea but karma is
impractical to do it in the batch
analysis this why at this point we don't
have the this kind of event detection in
fashion analysis yep
shake you dr. king our next question how
many maximal data files can be analyzed
in batch analysis well it is another
good question
actually actually I even I even I don't
know the answer I don't know but but we
have tests we have tests you know 100
data file you know we have tests open
100 data file okay that still can go
through okay and I believe that you know
also depends on you know the data file
the size of the data file right so and
this we test it with 100 data file and
in and then they went through so I and
then I hope that you can go up to more
than hundred but please let me know give
you more than hundred then let me know
ok there will be appreciated thank you
dr. ting now can the measurement and
results sheets be changed or modified
yes I'm sorry because I know that we saw
or the measurement cannot be changes
came but cannot be changed in the
analyse resolved or did it as a result
right I think that is that's good thing
right so it's not changeable
dr. Tang we have time for one final
question but I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today during our live
event and those that are submitted
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed by dr. Tang via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration dr. Tang can the data files
and data selector be removed oh this is
good question as I mentioned in my
presentation yet the answer's no right
the data imported in the data selector
cannot be removed that's why in the last
you know section of my presentation I
teach you how to create a new database
once you create a new database that the
data can be can be I mean the data in
the data set will be clear will be clean
then you open a new database so that you
can input the new data file to the new
database right that is the answer right
so that question I want to say a common
is that I hope you know I believe that
bash data analysis is a powerful feature
in country 11 so I hope that you know
you will save you a lot of time and hope
everyone enjoy this quick feature in
your research life thank you thank you
so much again to everyone and dr. Cheng
thank you for your time today and for
your important research we'd also like
to thank leverage and our sponsor
molecular devices for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and labret swill
alert you via email when it is available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now and we hope to see you again
soon have a great day